But do you realize what you are saying Do you realize the harm you are
doing to the democracy you represent here Do you realize that you are
tracing the silence of the extremes and the extreme right.
François Barouin is a,
mother of 3,
whose father was a great,
he is a former young man from politics.
How you can throw anathema at each other without proof,
by adding up tweets,
blogs of people settling accounts,
political opponents who don't even share your values How
you can continue on that path You are.
Ah he is handsome eh Ha ha ha And 1 p'tite wick the hair in the wind Uh he is handsome
he has 1 pretty voice especially he has 1 very beautiful woman too.
The surgeon,
by definition,
was supposed to be the successor of our national Chichi,
but unfortunately his career was not what it should have been.
He is right-wing before Marine Le Pen,
less extreme Yeah Republicans,
that's it Before Le Pen and then it's Le Pen and
before there's Macron He's not bad eh,
so he's not bad.
In the name of a certain idea that we have 1 sharing of democracy,
of the Republic,
do not play the game of the extreme right I beg you,
Mr.
Brian,
sit down Mr.
Ferrand,
Mr.
sit down.